si queremos saber la cantidad de agua
que llena un contenedor como este y
conocemos estos datos cómo podemos
encontrar la cantidad que cabe en total
preguntarnos por el agua que llena este
contenedor es otra forma de preguntar
cuál es su volumen de manera particular
nos interesa esta forma ya que no es una
de las típicas formas que se estudian no
es un cono tampoco un cilindro pero si
lo piensas bien es algo entre un cono y
un cilindro porque baja de esta forma
pero no completamente como para crear un
cono entonces llamamos a esto un tronco
de un cono me gusta pensarlo como una
cubeta un vaso o un cono de helado creo
que estudiamos esta forma en concreto
porque una cubeta es una forma típica y
saber qué cantidad de agua cabe en una
cubeta
algo que de hecho nos puede interesar en
el mundo real entonces como la obtenemos
bueno tal vez podríamos buscar su
fórmula estoy seguro que alguien ya la
obtuvo para esta forma en particular en
donde se introduce esta longitud esta
otra longitud y esta y obtienes el
volumen pero si eres como yo y no te
acuerdas o no te la sabes o no quieres
recordarla entonces la forma de resolver
esto es la misma que hemos trabajado en
otros problemas darnos cuenta de que
esta forma es poco familiar y
preguntarnos si podemos representarla
como un sólido que nos sea más familiar
y en este caso la respuesta es si
podemos pensar en un cono más grande del
que ha sido cortado un cono más pequeño
tenemos una forma que nos es familiar y
que sabemos su fórmula
si recordamos la fórmula para encontrar
el volumen de un cono es un tercio por
pi por el radio al cuadrado por la
altura así que si calculamos el volumen
de este cono grande y le restamos el
volumen del cono menor entonces
obtendremos el volumen del tronco esta
es una estrategia y podríamos hacerlo
pero nos faltan datos de algunas
longitudes ahora vamos a etiquetar los
datos que nos faltan nos hace falta la
altura del cono pequeño y la altura del
cono grande ahora aunque no nos han dado
la información de manera directa nos la
han dado de manera indirecta a partir
del momento en que nos dieron esta
longitud y esta otra y esta altura sólo
podemos tener una cubeta con esas
dimensiones lo que significa que sólo
existe un único cono que la completa
pero como encuentro esta altura h1 la
idea clave es que necesitamos pensar en
este triángulo yo sé que es un cono pero
si nos fijamos en una sección
transversal tendremos un triángulo aquí
también tenemos un triángulo y son
triángulos semejantes este ángulo es
igual este ángulo es recto este también
es un ángulo recto así que podemos
aplicar el criterio de semejanza
si queremos ser precisos entonces
podemos escribir que este lado entre
este lado es igual a este lado entre
este otro lado buscamos una relación tal
que se puede utilizar para obtener una
ecuación que conecte mi incógnita h1 con
los datos que tenemos así que ahora
podemos escribir esta ecuación podemos
escribir que h1 / h todos
es igual a 6 entre 9 ahora bien
por fortuna h 2 no es independiente de
h1 h2 es igual a h1 más 4 así que puedo
regresar a esta ecuación y escribir en
lugar de h 2h 14 y quedarnos con una
ecuación de una incógnita que se puede
resolver
es momento de multiplicar y encontrar la
respuesta 9 h 1 es igual a 6 que
multiplica a h 14 esto es lo mismo que
seis veces h 1 + 6 por 4 que es 24 y
ahora podemos restar seis veces h uno de
ambos lados y obtenemos que tres veces h
uno es igual a 24 y finalmente obtenemos
que h1 es igual a 8 centímetros esta es
la idea clave ser capaz de visualizar
este cono de abajo y usar la semejanza
para encontrar esta h1 ahora podemos
resolver para h2h 2 es igual a y bueno h
1 es igual a 8 centímetros esta otra
altura es 4 centímetros
entonces h 2 es igual a 8 + 4 que es 12
centímetros
ya hemos hecho todo el trabajo pesado
para resolver este problema entonces es
momento de calcular el volumen del cono
grande que es un tercio por pi por el
radio al cuadrado llamaremos a este
radio r 2 por r 2 al cuadrado por h 2
ese es el volumen de este cono grande ya
esto queremos restarle el volumen del
cono pequeño que es un tercio por pi por
el radio al cuadrado
entonces será por r 1 al cuadrado y esto
por h1 puedes darte cuenta de que ahora
tenemos todos los datos
r2 es un dato y resolvimos a h 2 r 1 es
un dato y resolvimos a h1 lo que
significa que ahora podemos hacer estos
cálculos sin error alguno así que
hagámoslo podemos sacar como factor
común
un tercio por pi y obtenemos que un
tercio por pi que lo aproximaremos con
22 séptimos ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por ere 2 que es 9 al cuadrado mejor
escribiré 81 y esto lo multiplicamos por
h 2 que es 12 así que es 81 por 12 que
escribiré con este otro símbolo de
multiplicación menos r1 elevado al
cuadrado que es lo mismo que 6 elevado
al cuadrado que es igual a 36 por h1 que
es hoy podemos observar que todos estos
son números y el resultado será dado en
centímetros cuadrados podemos continuar
de hacer estas cuentas y al hacer los
cálculos el resultado que obtuve fue de
716 puntos 57 centímetros cúbicos o
podemos decir que tenemos 700 16.57 ml
ya que un centímetro cúbico es un
mililitro o aproximadamente 0.72 litros
de hecho es menor que un litro pero
cercano a 750 mililitros tal vez no sea
una cubeta por el tamaño tal vez sea un
vaso grande pero lo que quiero que sepas
es que la única forma de que un problema
como éste sea difícil es tener números
que se vuelvan realmente enredados con
algunos decimales o algo así los
cálculos que nos quitarán algunos
minutos pero puedes darte cuenta que
realizar esta parte en una calculadora
es muy sencillo por lo que el método a
seguir es muy directo calculamos el
volumen del cono grande ya eso le
quitamos el volumen del cono pequeño
para resolver la altura del cono pequeño
usamos triángulos semejantes y con esa
altura calculamos la altura del cono
grande después restamos a ambos
volúmenes
es un poco extraño cuando tus cálculos
se vuelven muy grandes pero no debemos
dudar del método que utilizamos solo
porque los números son grandes ya que yo
dudé un poco al menos cuando intenté
resolver este tipo de preguntas creo que
esto que construimos es mucho más útil
que solo introducir los datos en la
fórmula y no proporcionar ninguna
intuición